MATTHEW MCNULTY: Good afternoon
and welcome to Polymer
and the Web
Components Revolution.
If this is not the talk
you thought you were in,
we've barred the doors.
So first just a
little bit about me.
My name is Matthew McNulty.
And I lead the Polymer
team here at Google.
I started actually
two years ago today.
I came to Google
to build Polymer.
So my total Twitter
handle is on there.
It's @mattsmcnulty.
And so feel free tweet
me throughout the show.
I don't have my phone on me.
So just a little bit about
what we're going to do today.
So the first thing is going to
be give an overview of Polymer.
We will also be talking about
the ecosystem of which Polymer
is a part, and discussing
material design on the web.
But to start, at
the keynote, you
might have seen a glimpse of an
app the Polymer team has been
working on over
the last few weeks.
And we code-named it Topeka
for entirely esoteric reasons.
It actually has nothing to
do with the city Kansas.
But in fact, it's a
trivia application.
So we spent a lot of
time over the last year
shipping web components
natively, building elements,
and evolving Polymer.
But the true test of all that
is building an application.
So Topeka is the app we built
to test Polymer and material
design.
So it's a real app.
And a handful of
Polymer engineers
built it over just
the last three weeks.
So just like the rest of
Polymer, it's open source
and we've made it public today.
So here's the URL.
And the QR Code shortcut
so you can follow along.
This works best on Chrome
beta and Canary on 37.
So that's pretty cool.
Everyone is actually doing that.
Works great on
desktops and works
on other platforms as well, but
it's best on beta and Canary
locally.
So just a little note.
Since this was shown and tweeted
about during the keynote,
I think we're up to about
5,000 or 6,000 users so far.
So our big plan to show
the leader board of all the
over time during this talk
probably is going for naught.
But welcome to join in.
All right.
So I'm going to demo Topeka.
So we can take it over
to the demo machine.
Wrong demo machine.
There we go.
All right.
So this is Topeka.
I'm running it locally,
because of internet issues
at conferences.
At the very beginning,
you've got a sign in page.
And you can see
from the beginning
that we've got these cool
ink effects on the inputs.
Let me put my stuff in here.
And you pick an avatar.
So I usually pick the dog,
because I'm a dog person.
And from the very beginning,
you see really cool transitions.
And this is all built-in
and part of Polymer.
We can show that one again.
So it's really, really cool.
So let's pick out a category.
Let's do food and drink.
So it's important to
note at the start,
that we are not trivia experts.
So some of the answers were
actually wrong as recently
as a week ago.
And some of these
are incredibly hard.
There's this one
coming up that I
don't think I've ever
actually gotten right.
And I haven't looked at.
All right.
Audience participation time.
Name the Italian, semi-soft,
rich cheese with blue veins
through it.
AUDIENCE: Gorgonzola.
MATTHEW MCNULTY: That's
a smart audience.
All right.
Coffee beans contain more
caffeine than tea leaves.
AUDIENCE: False.
MATTHEW MCNULTY: This
is a good audience.
Now we get to the question
that I have gotten wrong
Every single time.
AUDIENCE: Honey.
MATTHEW MCNULTY: OK.
We've got honey.
AUDIENCE: Water.
MATTHEW MCNULTY: Yaaaayyy.
Somehow I was missing
water in all that.
That makes no sense at all.
All right.
So there you go.
There's the categories.
We can check out
the leader board,
see how everyone's doing.
Actually, there's
people who have
done remarkably
well this morning.
I think we did this
test in the Chrome team.
Someone was in the 400s,
but that was about it.
So someone has done pretty well.
We even have a
standalone, one that
shows a little more
completely-- once it loads up.
Welcome to conference internet.
Come on.
Always have a backup plan.
All right.
So as you can see now,
no one has any scores.
But as it goes and as we batch
the updates and animate around,
it's really pretty cool.
And you can see a little bit
of the material design aspects
here as the pieces of
paper come off the screen
and then mold back in as
they get to their new spot.
So we'll check and see if the
leader board works later on.
But another thing to not about
this is that its responsive.
So if we come back
to the app and I
pop out of full screen mode.
So the same app actually adapts
across phones and tablets
with the same animations.
So this is cool.
But we need to
actually prove it.
So if we go over
to the WolfVision.
Here we are.
So you see how this is
exactly the same app.
This is running in
Chrome Beta on Nexus 5.
Now we know the answer.
So it's pretty cool.
So you can see, it's actually
the same fast, smooth animation
and the same responsive design
across mobile and desktop.
So let's go back to
the presentation.
All right.
So that's Topeka.
We'll check back later.
See if the leader board works
and see how everyone's doing
but probably won't.
So for those of you I haven't
lost to playing trivia.
And this is the big problem
with this application,
is even showing
it to executives,
they get immersed
in the actual trivia
and lose everything
else that I'm saying.
This is the kind of immersive
experience typically associated
with native applications
on mobile devices.
So you might be thinking,
but this is the web,
and the web isn't supposed
to be able to do this.
The web is for content.
The web is for documents.
The web is for the
boring stuff that you
stick in the middle
of a hybrid app.
So how did we actually do this?
We did it with Polymer.
And I'm here today
to show you how.
So to start.
What in the world is Polymer?
So Polymer is a library that
makes building applications
easier, which sounds
pretty generic.
So let's dive into a
little bit more detail.
So if you take away anything
from this talk, make it this.
Polymer is a different
kind of thing.
So all comparisons to
other things and things
that have come before and
perfect, because there hasn't
been anything like this before.
So first off, the process
of building Polymer
was very different.
And the reason is pretty simple.
The Polymer team is
part of the Chrome team.
So when we started this
project two years ago today,
we were given a mandate.
And that mandate was
use the platform.
So previously, best practices
included building frameworks
that are above the
web platform or even
bring their own platform
they stick on top.
So some just use
the web platform
like a rendering layer,
like our last framework.
And as a result, Polymer
doesn't fight the platform.
Because we're on the web
platform team at Chrome.
It's us.
So there's a room full of
people in multiple offices
who surround us who are
responsible for making the web
platform great.
And they keep us honest and keep
us from using our bag of tricks
to get around problems.
And we keep them honest by
stopping when we find something
that doesn't work and filing
bugs or pointing it out.
And a lot of times the person
responsible is a few feet away.
I can think of a couple
people in particular.
So if we run across some
source of jank or something
that doesn't seem
to work right, we
yell across the room for
someone to take a look at it,
and bugs are filed.
And the next version
of Chrome gets better,
and Polymer gets better,
and more importantly,
the whole web
platform gets better.
So Polymer is the first
library of its kind.
It's not just because we
are part of the Chrome team.
Because it's made from
a different foundation.
It's made from different parts.
And that foundation
is web components.
So who here has heard
of web components?
All right.
That's pretty good.
If you haven't,
you definitely want
to stay right here
for the next talk
because Eric Bidelman is
going to talk all about that
and Polymer in a lot of depth.
So web components are
a set of new standards.
And my slide formatting got
a little screwed up here.
So you'll have to
bear with me there.
So there's standards
on the bottom.
So Polymer isn't
just a Chrome thing.
It's a web platform
thing, and Polymer is just
leading the way so far.
This slide formatting
is killing me.
So if you don't know
about web components,
you might know this already,
but if you don't, here it is.
So web components utterly
change the web platform.
So we use lots of
grandiose terms
and we talk about
this revolution,
changes everything you know.
This isn't hyperbole.
This actually
changes everything.
And web components
introduce a new world
where components from
different vendors
can live together
on the same page.
So apps can be
crafted out of parts
that are found on
a massive shelf.
So the web becomes interoperable
with custom elements, which
is what that's supposed to say.
So web components make
composing applications out
of these components possible.
So shadow DOM is about
composability and only that.
So a lot of people think
it's about security,
but that's not really true.
So it gives you just enough
of a container-- just enough--
that the web becomes
composable with shadow DOM.
And finally, web components
introduces resource loading
and external
dependencies to HTML.
So think about it.
How long have you been able to
have external CSS and JS files,
but never HTML?
So it's a really
simple mechanism,
but it's really useful.
So the web is now
consumable in smaller chunks
with HTML imports.
And all of this will
start shipping natively
starting in Chrome 36, which
is the beta channel right now.
And it will be stable
in just a few weeks.
So does this work
only on Chrome?
No.
So thanks to polyfills, this
works across more browsers
than you think.
It's actually the
last two versions
of just about everything.
So there's a
misconception out there
that Polymer is the polyfill
layer for web components,
because we happen to write them.
And that's what we
talked about last year.
But the polyfills
aren't Polymer,
but let Polymer elements
and applications
run on other recent browsers.
All right.
So Polymer is based
on web components
and web components are awesome.
But what does
polymer actually do?
What's it's purpose in life?
So Polymer provides a sugaring
layer on top of these new web
standards, so web components,
as well as others,
like the template tag.
So it tries to be a
thin layer on top.
But since these new
standards are so awesome,
why do they need sugaring?
It's because primitives
are primitive.
So this sounds
funny, but it's true.
Think about l right the best
LEGOS aren't the weird castle
wall chunks or specialty bricks
that all of my older siblings
claimed are complete sacrilege.
They're the basic ones, right?
Because they are
the most expressive.
So new features should be
as primitive as possible.
So developers can
do things with them
that browser vendors
would never dream of.
And Polymer reduces boilerplate.
So for various very
legitimate reasons,
primitive APIs can require a lot
of boilerplate code or quirks
that can get really,
really repetitive.
Our goal of Polymer is to reduce
the code that developers write
to just what is unique
to their application.
So DRY is our motto--
don't repeat yourself.
So Polymer also introduces
a declarative syntax.
So web components in fact has
a declarative syntax in there,
but it's not been
implemented yet.
So we built our own on
top of the imperative.
So this makes it really simple
to describe your UI in markup.
So Polymer makes all these
new bits work together great.
So a lot of times
over the last year,
there are people who set
off to do this on their own
and do it without Polymer,
because they decided, Oh,
Polymer will be some big thing
and they have to figure out.
So they try and get it
all working on their own.
And they do, but it's
a lot harder that way.
So Polymer does
all the hard work
to make this all
a cohesive system.
And Polymer can do all this,
because Polymer has an opinion.
So we think we have a great way
to build applications and use
all these new features
together to create
awesome experiences for users.
So there isn't a
place for opinion
in standards you
need another layer.
So let's take a
look more closely
about how you can use Polymer.
So when we talk
about using Polymer,
we divide the world
into two use cases,
using elements and
creating elements.
So the long tail
of users out there
just want to add something
to their website,
like DHTML calendar that
people have been using forever.
It was on every website in the
2000s, or a download button
or this thing or that thing.
Using elements is something that
web components and some best
practices make
possible right now.
But the people in this room
that are listening to this talk
are likely also interested in
creating their own elements
and using all of the
Polymer features to do so.
So let's cover using
elements first,
because it's really easy.
So the first step is find
the element you want.
You can do this a lot of ways.
There's GitHub-- we like Bower
on the team-- or catalogs.
We're building one.
There's some others out
there already Actually
Or just a zip file
hosted somewhere.
Step two is to import it.
This is where HTML
imports comes in.
This link tag with rel equals
import is an HTML important.
So you'll notice what
it's importing is HTML.
In this case, it's
the HTML file that
has the definition of my button.
And the last step, there's
only three steps is use it.
So once the element
is imported, you
can use them on the page
just like any other element.
And that's.
That's all there is to using
custom elements with web
components.
And Polymer elements just like
custom elements in general
are just HTML elements.
So I put "just' in quotes
here, because now that HTML
is extensible like
this, HTML elements
become a really powerful.
And with this new power,
it becomes possible again
to use DOM as the object
model as it was originally
intended to be.
So we like to call Polymer
a library not a framework.
I mess this up a lot.
I might even today.
Because with Polymer, the
framework is DOM itself.
It's a return to the
early days of HTML
when your UI was
expressed in HTML
and manipulated using non-APIs.
Let's take at look at how we
create elements with Polymer.
So we identified the
most common things
developers will need to do
to create web components
and focused on making
that dead simple.
So this is the sugar
that we're layering
on top of web components.
So we use this simple counter
elements as an example,
just as a label, a value,
and a button to increment.
Oops.
I get that video working.
That's interesting.
It doesn't actually animate
on my screen, only yours.
So using standard APIs, creating
and registering your counter
might look something like this.
And that's a lot of typing.
It works, but that's
not really sweet.
With Polymer, we can
accomplish the most common task
declaratively and
with much less code.
So the boilerplate's
gone and you're
left with code that's unique
to your application, which
I mentioned is our goal.
So let's take a
quick look at some
of the features Polymer adds
on top of web components
in a little more detail
using this exact example.
So first, you can create and
register and customize it
declaratively without
any JavaScript.
So you just wrap your definition
in a Polymer element tag
and give it a name.
So now my counter
is a valid HTML tag,
you can use in your app.
It just doesn't do anything yet.
Next we can include
additional templates
in the element that captures
this element's view.
So it can contain any arbitrary
HTML including other custom
elements.
Here we'll put a couple
of divs and a button
in to make our counter.
It's pretty just standard HTML.
So next we have styles
for our templates.
So since the template will
be rendered into the Shadow
DOM, hidden from other
elements, these styles
will only modify our component
and will leak out and modify
other parts of the application.
So this is how Shadow DOM
enables composability.
Next, we can define
published properties
on the element's prototype.
So published
properties in Polymer
can be initialized
via attributes
on the tag and markup.
It observes simply by adding
a changed handler function.
Polymer comes with
two-way data binding,
which binds the
values of our elements
to the view using
mustache syntax.
So Polymer supports complex
expressions, but in this case,
we're just binding the
contents of this span
to the value of the counter
property on the prototype.
We also provide
event binding, which
raises the boilerplate needed
to set up event handlers.
So in this case, when
the button is tapped
it calls this method on
a prototype increment
and increments the counter.
And all this together makes
defining and composing
your custom elements a lot
easier, maybe even sweet.
So with all this what
can you make a Polymer?
I get asked this a lot.
And the answer is absolutely
everything or everything.
So whole cities even, if
you believe this photo.
The truth is Polymer is a
really low level UI library
and it can express a
lot of different things,
like quiz apps.
So at least we know
it's good for quiz apps.
We've made very,
very good quiz apps.
We can also use Polymer
to make apps out
of elements and elements
out of other elements.
With Polymer everything is
elements all the way down.
Those are the core
building blocks.
You can also use
Polymer to build
sets of elements,
pre-defined building blocks
that others can use to build
elements or applications.
Some of those elements are
visual, like buttons, and tabs,
and sliders, and inputs,
and all the standard things
you'd need to
build applications.
But other elements
are utility elements
that don't have the UI.
So this can sometimes
strike people as strange.
But if you think about it, HTML
has script tags, a head tag,
title tag, style tag.
These all don't necessarily
have any UI at all,
but they're still HTML elements.
Polymer didn't
invent this concept.
So the first set of elements
we've been creating out
in the open over
the last few months
is Polymer Core Elements.
So these are basic elements
that are generally useful
and don't have a lot of style.
There were some
blogs that thought
this was the future
of Google style,
but they intentionally
don't have a lot.
So some of them are
utility elements
you would find in
frameworks in the past,
but with Polymer
those don't have
to be baked in at that level
and can be used a la carte.
So there's a few dozen
of these core elements
and these are just
a few of them.
So it's everything from icons
and tooltips and buttons
and some of those utility
elements like core-ajax.
So core-ajax makes
Ajax calls dead simple.
core-localstorage
makes persistence
as easy as binding any object
to it with data- binding.
You've got a piece of data.
You bind it to your local
storage and it persists.
And that's it.
That's all you have to do.
So all the core elements
start with a core- namespace.
And as we move forward, you're
going to see more of the gaps
in Polymer fields using
elements like these.
So we get asked about routing
or internationalization.
We have some of those
experiments already out there.
But you'll see these show up in
the future likely as elements,
not baked into Polymer itself.
So over the last
six months, we've
been working on another
set of elements,
ones that push the boundaries
of what's possible on the web.
Today, we're
unveiling another set
of elements that's part of
the material design effort.
And we call them paper elements.
So material design unifies
the user experience
across all devices
and allows developers
to create rich,
immersive experiences.
So here's a quick look at
what we've made public today.
So we built a sampler app that
showcases the various paper
elements for developers and
that's also available today.
It's linked off our homepage.
And this is just a
brief taste of it.
So let's take a look.
So we've got check boxes and
radio buttons, toggle buttons.
And all of this reacts
to both mouse and touch.
So it works across
mobile and desktop alike.
We have really cool input tags.
They have that ink effect
I showed you earlier.
We've got a validation.
That's pretty cool.
We even have these neat
floating label ones,
which we like to use
a lot, because it's
a really neat effect.
So you see us use those
all over the place.
So all of these are
available today.
They're all in the sampler.
And they're all a
work in progress
and they're going to
continue to evolve.
So we've also introduced
a bunch of primitives
to create really
fancy animations.
So from cross-fading,
scrolling headers the return on
scroll up-- like you
see it right now--
to systems that allow
the UI to animate
across states while the focused
object or hero morphs across.
So this is one of the
principles of material design,
is that the object that's
in focus to the user
should stay as you morph across
these different surfaces.
So when you put it all
together, you get Topeka.
And this is a little video
that they showed this morning
in the keynote that shows you
how it all comes together.
And this is all public today
on the Polymer website.
So the title of the talk
mentioned a revolution.
And this is all
certainly revolutionary
for web development.
But Polymer is only a smaller
part of a bigger story.
And this is the ecosystem that
web components is creating.
So Polymer is at the
forefront of this revolution.
We are the pioneer,
to mix my metaphors.
But we're not alone
in this endeavor.
Others have already joined us.
So our friends in Mozilla built
a similar library called x-tags
and have began a set of
elements called brick.
So x-tags and brick are roughly
analogous to Polymer and paper
elements.
So both Polymer and
x-tags are built
on top of the same
polyfills, the ones we
announced last year.
So because of web
components, these libraries
can compliment each other.
We're not actually competing
and can work together,
because developers
can mix and match.
So Polymer is bootstrapping
this entire ecosystem.
There's already
registries of elements
like a customelements.io,
Component Kitchen
is a cool effort
by a friend of ours
to build a catalog
for these components.
And webcomponents.org
exists for web developers
to exchange ideas on
these core concepts.
And all these are in addition to
the Polymer website and mailing
list that we're creating.
So as you can imagine most of
this work started from scratch.
And it's a really good job.
So we're moving on a lot of
these fronts all at once.
This new ecosystem and method
for building applications
out of all these
individual components
requires a lot of new tools.
Some of those tools
we're building.
So last year, I showed off
a demo of the designer tool
for components and I used it
extensively during my talk.
This year we've made it look
more real or made it more real.
So you can use it to
prototype and build elements
and save and share them.
So we call it Polymer designer.
We recently put it up
on our website as well.
And an updated
version launched today
and we'll take a look
at it in a minute.
And one thing we hear a lot
is about how building apps out
of discrete components,
breaks network performance
optimizations by causing
a lot of requests.
So we built a tool called
Vulcanizer for deployment,
can bundle together all of
your imports and components
into a single CSS,
JS, and HTML files .
So it even has flags for
deploying to CSP environments.
And testing is
also an area we're
working hard on that
people have asked us about.
So right now we are using
Karma, Chai, and Mocha.
And we built a harness for Mocha
that enables HTML-based test,
rather than just JavaScript
as unit tests are done today.
We've even built element
called core component page that
can look at a component and
create a nice documentation
page for it.
All you need to
do is include one
in the index of HTML of your
repo and the rest just works.
So we've seen how
Polymer can be used
to create immersive experiences
across devices, across phones,
tablets, and desktops--
anywhere the web goes
and that means TVs with
Chromecast as well.
So Polymer and web components
goes everywhere the web goes.
And the web has massive reach.
So in fact, my
friend Alex has been
working for the last few
weeks on a component that
lets me push notifications
to a watch from a web app.
And I happen to have
a watch right here.
With web components, I can
go find the element I need,
import it, and use it.
So let's see how this
all works together.
Go over to the demo machine.
Which one's asleep?
See if the leader
board is working
while that's loading up.
So here we have the catalog.
This is the catalog
we've been working on.
It's not public yet, because
it's still pretty much
a work in progress.
And I happen to know
that the element I need
is called notification elements.
So I can come to our
catalog and download it.
And that gives me options
to download and zip
the commands for
Bower or GitHub.
GitHub is a little dangerous,
because it doesn't pull down
all the dependencies for
you like the other ones.
So let's go with the zip.
So now imagine,
through the magic of IO
that that magically got
over into my designer here.
So we'll act like that
just kind of happens.
So this is the designer tool,
which I talked about before.
So we've got a
large canvas area,
looks like we had last year
That's a little updated.
And then on the right
hand side, we've
got a Property
Inspector that allows
you to inspect the properties
of something you dragged
and a pallet of
components to drag out
and a tree that lets
you select things that
are in the canvas that might
not otherwise be selectable.
So we're going to add
notifications to Topeka.
So first, I'm to
drag out the app.
And like everything
in Polymer, everything
is an element, everything
works in the designer tool.
So I can actually drag
out the whole application,
maximize it and I need to
connected it to a data source.
So I'll do that.
And then I have to
connect the two together.
So let's give it a user.
So I already logged
in on this machine
when I was doing
the demo earlier,
so it already has
the user local.
And let's give it categories.
So this is all
just using the data
binding features I was
talking about before.
We have our whole app.
So this actually
works right here
in the middle of the designer.
It's pretty neat.
But we want to
add notifications.
So let me come back
here to components,
grab our notification element.
So this is one of
those utility elements.
It doesn't have the UI.
And it has a hard
coded message to begin
with that says, hi there.
So let's fix that and instead
to Topekaapp.user.score.
So now when the
notification is triggered,
it will push the
score to the device.
But there's still a little bit
I have to do to wire it up.
So let' flip over to code view.
So this is the code
that we're creating.
And notice that so far, I've
done no JavaScript whatsoever.
This is all just HTML
and data binding.
So I'm going to add an event
handler to the quiz, which
I happen to know is
called onQuizDone.
And I'm going to use
the event binding,
so that it will call this method
when this event is triggered.
And now I actually
have define the method.
So what I did there is when
the onQuizDone event happens,
it calls quizDone grabs the
notification alert element
that's sitting here on
the page right here,
triggers it's notify
method, and gives it
a message of
Topekaapp.user.score.
And now if the demo gods are
shining on me a little better
than they were before,
I should be able
go over the whole
vision in a second.
Let me not show off my password
to all of I/O. Reload it.
I'm sorry.
Wrong one.
That was my fault.
I'm just going to
sign in here really
quickly, because
that's the boring part.
All right.
So we have our app here.
So people tell me that you
don't want to demo anything
with Wi-Fi or internet.
And apparently
Bluetooth is even worse
in an environment like this.
So who knows if this is
actually going to work.
But let's go back to
our favorite category
and answer the questions
we know about all ready.
Gorgonzola.
Hey.
There we go.
It pushed eight to the device.
It went to sleep at
exactly the wrong time.
[APPLAUSE]
Bring it back to
the presentation.
So that's just a little
taste of the ecosystem that's
being powered by Polymer
and web components.
So what did we
learn about today.
So we've learned that web
components are awesome.
And if you want to
know how awesome,
Eric's going to talk about
that in a little bit.
We learned about
Polymer itself and how
to build elements
and use elements.
We've learned that we've built
a lot of elements already
and they come in
two different sets
so far-- core and
paper elements.
And there's a lot of
other ones out there.
And Polymer is just a small
part of a really big ecosystem
that's starting.
It's all powered
by web components.
So this ecosystem is
just getting started.
And there's a lot you can
do to join the revolution.
So you can build an
element, wrap an API.
So this has gotten
really popular at Google.
So a lot of people
building like cloud APIs
or even browser APIs
that have figured out
that if you wrap their
API in a custom element,
it makes it really consumable
and easy for developers to use
and they can also stick
it in a designer tool,
and it's really fun.
You can build an app.
So we built one.
Now it's your turn.
We would prefer it
not be a quiz app,
because we've already done that.
You can stay put for Eric's
talk in just a little bit, right
here in the same room, and
come check out Robert at 4:00.
So the ecosystem
just getting started,
but we're also just
getting started.
So public today is the
Polymer Developer Preview,
the paper elements
also went public today,
new version of designer,
brand new tutorial, whole new
boarding experience,
documentation for everything.
It's all still a
work in progress,
but it's all public
and available today
at polymerproject.org.
So that's Polymer.
So we'll do some Q&A
in just a minute,
but I just wanted to give
you a quick reminder.
So if you stay here,
in about 29 minutes,
Eric Bidelman will
Polymer and web components
change everything you know
about web development, which
is officially the longest
title in I/O history.
And then at 4
o'clock in Room four,
which is pretty
easy to remember,
It's unlock the Next Era of
UI Development with Polymer.
And Rob Dodson is
doing that talk.
And he's going to do a really
deep dive on the material
design and paper elements
aspect of Polymer.
It's going to be really cool.
So there's the thank you slide.
There's the feedback URL.
I appreciate any
feedback you have there.
And let's go to questions.
AUDIENCE: My questions are
about material design, which
makes me wonder if
I'm in the wrong talk.
But I noticed that when you
shrank the browser window
to begin with, that the
elements didn't re-size with it.
Is there a vision to do
that with Polymer paper
to where when you
responsively re-size a window,
the elements will
still track in place
rather than just popping
between media queries?
MATTHEW MCNULTY:
I think it depends
on which screen you're viewing.
So I think it depends
on how it's set up.
Right now, we've got it set up
to have a card in the middle
and it changes as you go.
Depending on which scaffold
you use and how you build it,
some are of them are more
responsive than that.
So it really depends.
Most of the widgets are whatever
width of their container.
So if the container changes
size, it will just change size.
AUDIENCE: And the
follow up to that.
I know that Polymer
is very cool,
but it's also very much
a prototype right now.
And for people who are building
projects that need to get out
the door today are
using frameworks
like Angular or something else.
Will there be a
way to incorporate
Polymer paper and some of the
cool UX things you guys are
doing with other frameworks or
do you have to throw it away
and start from
scratch with Polymer?
MATTHEW MCNULTY: That's one
of the really cool things
about custom elements is that
they're just HTML elements.
So anything that knows
how to deal with HTML
can also use Polymer elements.
So one of the things we
like to talk about with this
is that there's this barrier.
There's the world
outside of an element
and there's the world
inside of an element.
So from the outside,
Polymer elements
look just like every
other HTML element,
so they have properties
and methods and attributes.
So they can be
consumed by anything
that uses HTML, or pushes out.
It's inside the
element that you have
all the goodies that
Polymer provides.
And that's where if you're
actually inside building
a Polymer element, and you
started to use other framework
you could get in trouble,
mostly because they
don't know how to do a Shadow
DOM and things like that.
But from just using elements,
including the material design
elements, you can
just do that today.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MATTHEW MCNULTY: Next.
We'll go in the back.
AUDIENCE: So two questions
about the ecosystem.
One, is there any
component directory
that's trying to include both
Polymer components as well
as x-tags components.
And then can you speak at all
about other browser support,
Safari in particular?
MATTHEW MCNULTY: Sure.
So to the first question,
so some of the ones
I showed you there,
like customelements.io
is a registry of all
elements, regardless
of whether they're
Polymer or not.
The catalog that
we're building is
intended to be just
web components and not
Polymer specific as well.
I think you saw
that in the title.
So I think the idea is
that it doesn't really
matter how you
built these again,
kind of going back to the
answer of the last question,
they can still be
consumed by everyone.
And what was the
second question?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Safari support
and any other browsers
that have committed.
MATTHEW MCNULTY: Sure.
So you're talking native
support specifically, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
MATTHEW MCNULTY: Yeah.
So Mozilla has
progressed quite a bit.
They've shipped Shadow DOM.
They have not shipped
custom elements yet.
They've shipped custom
elements, not Shadom DOM.
Sorry.
Had to look for a
little support there.
But they're working on it.
And they're working
it very actively
and we're talking to them a lot.
Safari, we don't really know.
They're not very
public with their plans
about these kinds of things.
have expressed interest in
the topic, especially lately.
And that's a really good sign,
but we don't really know.
The polyfill, so people who are
using this like Salesforce.com
have been using the polyfill,
especially for mobile Safari,
and have found the performance
to be pretty acceptable.
It depends on what
you're going for.
So people ask about
the performance
of the polyfills a lot, and it's
not really about performance.
It's more about
API compatibility.
But most people have found
it relatively respectable.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATTHEW MCNULTY: Answered
his question too.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: What about IE?
MATTHEW MCNULTY: The
question was, what about IE?
You want anything
official on that?
So IE has recently started
being a little bit more
open with everyone about
what their plans are.
And they seem to be
interested in web components.
We don't really know.
They don't tell
everyone their plans.
But they're involved.
You actually see them pop up on
our mailing list occasionally.
And they've done some
experiments internally
on WinJS and Polymer
together, that we've
helped contribute to.
So they seem very interested
in Polymer and web components
in general, but we're going
to have to wait and see.
In the back?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was wondering.
So what we've seen with
material design demos
today, the performance in
the browser looks incredible,
how much of that is unique
to work Polymer has done?
How much of that is
just continued work
by the Chrome team to
improve performance?
MATTHEW MCNULTY: Sure.
So they're actually
kind of intermixed
if you think about it.
So because we're part
of the Chrome team,
we're a lot of the people that
are causing the bugs to be
filed, that are
getting fixed, that
are causing things
to get faster.
And at the same time,
we're also codifying
a lot of the best practices
of the Chrome team
into the elements
themselves, so that when
people use them to
create things they're
automatically on
that well lit path.
So it's a combination of both.
Anything else?
Yeah.
One more.
AUDIENCE: Just a follow
up on the performance,
could you talk about the
long-term performance
of using DOM elements and DOM
manipulation versus frameworks
like React that try
to minimize DOM?
MATTHEW MCNULTY: Sure.
So it's definitely a
different world, right?
So to start off with,
today with the polyfills,
Polymer is basically as good as
any other existing JavaScript
frameworks out there.
We don't do anything worse.
So the idea is that it's
even better on Chrome.
That has native support.
So that's the first
thing I wanted to say.
The other thing is when the team
that works on Polymer, worked
on a framework called Enyo
at webOS, a few years ago--
philosophically, React
and Polymer and Enyo
are all kind of similar
with a component mindset,
but they had the idea of
you never touch the DOM.
The DOM is slow.
You never want to touch the DOM.
We'd actually just scored in in
our HTML, giant HTML strings.
That was the fastest path.
And then when we came to
Chrome, the guys at Chrome
were like, no that's crazy.
We were like, no, no,
this is the thing.
And it turns out
that that's actually
been changing a lot over time.
So once we actually
made it to Chrome,
the DOM APIs were
incredibly fast.
So it turned out not to be
the penalty we thought it was.
So I think that it's
an area of improvement
potentially for Chrome as well.
I know they've identified
a lot of things there.
It's all public on
the Blink mailing list
as to how to improve
DOM performance.
But what's great about it is by
relying on that core platform,
there's one point of failure.
There is one point that you
can use to improve performance
across everyone and
that's the Blink runtime.
If you have your own
whole framework on top
or that has a server component,
it's a lot of different things
that have to come together
and get faster all at once
to get there.
Anything else?
All right.
Thanks everyone.
[APPLAUSE]